ae
em 2015 eu decidi que eu ia parar de
produzir lixo
é eu sei muitos a fita certo
há cinco anos atrás quando fui morar
sozinha eu percebi uma coisa que me
incomodava muito
incomodava mas eu não sabia muito bem o
que fazer
era a quantidade de sacolas de lixo eu
colocava para fora toda semana
eram 15 sacolas de lixo mas aí tudo isso
mudou quando conhecer essa menina
a oren singer do blog trechos for tots
que numa tradução livre significa lixo
parede obras
eu li uma vilmar chamada de uma matéria
sobre ela que dizia que ela não produzir
lixo há três anos ea primeira coisa que
eu pensei foi sentida né como é que não
produz o lixo como assim como é que faz
mas aí eu fui ver a matéria sobre ela
entrei no blog dela e aí eu vi que
parecia ser muito possível e mais do que
isso
mas o que isso parecia ser muito fácil a
loren viver um estilo de vida lixo zero
o que significa que ela não produz nem
manda para os aterros sanitários nenhum
tipo de lixo
nada que não seja reciclável e mesmo o
lixo reciclável que ela produz é quase
zero
bom quando vi isso quando eu descobri
isso eu pensei eu quero ser assim eu
quero ser assim também eu quero não
produzir lixo aí eu vi uma coisa no blog
dela que me deixou muito chocada isso
uma escova de dente feita de bambu e aí
nesse ponto olhei falei não
isso não vai ter no brasil é impossível
não não vai dar
só que era um domingo neto vai impedir a
da ed they escova de dente de bambu para
comprar eu achei ayrton se tinha
aprendido escova de dente de bambu
o resto é fichinha fértil e aí que eu
criei o blog um ano sem lixo
é a minha primeira ideia foi já em 2015
não produziu nenhum tipo de lixo
mas aí com um pouco de pesquisa e vendo
a minha realidade no brasil eu percebi
que seria um pouco mais difícil que é
dar um pouco mais de trabalho então
decidi que 2015 a segunda transição que
eu ia aprender a parar de produzir lixo
é eu encontrei muito conteúdo
mas era tudo nos estados unidos no
canadá na austrália na frança ea gente
sabe que existem muitas diferenças entre
os países
então eu decidi que eu ia contar como
que dá pra fazer isso no brasil
bom mas como é que se deixe de produzir
lixo
a primeira coisa é que eu fiz é muito
óbvia eu precisava aprender a
identificar que tipo de lixo que
produzir
daí saber que tipo de problema eu
precisava resolver eu tinha cinco
grandes problemas
o lixo orgânico da cozinha a caixinha de
areia da minha gata papel higiênico as
embalagens de comida cosméticos e
produtos de limpeza e os lixos de quando
eu ia comer fora o lixo orgânico da
cozinha a solução foi bem fácil de achar
no eu comprei uma composteira do méxico
ela é um sistema de cachos com minhocas
que degrada matéria orgânica
transformando tudo em adubo
sem deixar o mau cheiro nenhum eu tenho
um apartamento para as compras de comida
é eu passei a comprar muitas coisas a
granel
então eu levo nossos próprios potes de
vidro ou menos saquinho de pano e compra
tudo é de indo direto pra mim instante
eu também comprei muita coisa sem
embalagem nas feiras estão frutas e
verduras eu não levo saquinho põe tudo
direto na minha sacola
eu também passei a fazer nos próprios
cosméticos para evitar as embalagens e
também para evitar os químicos
sintéticos nocivos
os cosméticos convencionais têm por
exemplo sulfatos parabenos triclosan
liberadores de formal e
esses todos químicos são comprovadamente
nocivos
eles estão ligados a um aumento de casos
de câncer em alguns estudos a a aumento
de energia há ressecamento de pele
cabelo
a inflamação de pele como espinhas e se
a gente é exposto a isso a vida inteira
em pasta de dente xampu condicionador e
tem inclusive em produtos voltados para
bebês porque que a gente não procura uma
solução que seja mais barata mais
natural e fácil né
então eu passei a usar um xampu em barra
que é mais natural e assim evita
embalagens
eu faço minha própria pasta de dente com
óleo de coco e bicarbonato de sódio eu
faço o meu próprio da trama hidratante e
toda vez que acaba alguma coisa eu
procuro uma receita para fazer em casa o
produto para os produtos de limpeza e
reduzir todos eles apenas três coisas
sabão de coco ho e carbonato de sódio e
vinagre de álcool
eu faço meu próprio sabão em pó e eu
limpe a casa muito mais naturalmente
com isso com essa troca só nos produtos
de limpeza e reduzir em cerca de 70% o
valor mensal o que eu gostava nesses
produtos
bom papel higiênico é provavelmente foi
a primeira coisa que vocês pensaram
quando falei que nem produzir lixo
eu sei o papel higiênico é um item bem
mais problemático principalmente no
brasil que a gente não pode jogar no
vaso é por isso eu decidi que vou parar
de usar eu vou instalar uma ducha
higiênica no banheiro e usar toalhinhas
reutilizáveis em tamanho de lenços
umidecidos é a idéia é limpá direto para
um balde de molho awa avó nova para os
lixos de quando eu ia comer fora eu
bolei um kit de coisas pra ter sempre na
bolsa
então eu tenho sempre na bolsa
guardanapo de pano um copo retrátil ou
uma garrafa de vidro talheres
assim eu reduzo muito todas aquelas
coisas que a gente usa quando vai comer
fora
sim eu tenho uma ecografia
até os animais tiveram mudança lá em
casa para a caixinha de areia da nina eu
achei o mar e biodegradável que é feita
de serragem e pode no vaso
a flot chegou depois na família também
tem uma história tem um sanitário
caminho que é uma espécie de caixinha de
areia para gato que é uma bandinha de
plástico com uma telinha por cima e dá
pra por alguma coisa dentro pelo senhor
vê o xixi no caso dela e usa a mesma
areia daninha bom mas quais foram as
mudanças na minha vida né
muita gente me pergunta tá tudo muito
tina você gasta mais dinheiro é muito
mais caro
você perde mais tempo e eu queria saber
de vocês agora vocês acham que eu perco
mais tempo fazendo vivendo nesse estilo
de vida quem achar pode levantar não
levantar a mão bom ea resposta é não não
por incrível que pareça uma das coisas
que mais mudou foi a quantidade de tempo
que o gasto para fazer compras
antes eu ia todo dia no mercado hoje em
dia não hoje em dia eu vou uma vez por
semana em lojas a granel não momento eu
vou uma vez por semana em feiras comprar
frutas e verduras e reabasteceu estoque
mas a loja a granel vou de vez em quando
porque grãos duro mais antes de ver todo
dia no mercado eu perdia muito tempo
porque o mercado é um lugar grande cheia
de distrações tem estacionamento tem
caixa tem fila você sempre acaba
comprando uma coisa que você não precisa
bom mas além do tempo uma coisa que
diminuiu muito foi o dinheiro que eu
gastava é muita gente acha que é muito
mais caro viver assim mas não é muito
mais barato eu gasto menos dinheiro que
eu compre menos comida eu quero jogar
menos comida fora que eu percebi que eu
jogava muito comida fora
então se eu compro menos comida eu jogo
- fora e eu gasto menos dinheiro mas
como a mesma coisa eu também gastar
menos dinheiro
o que eu penso muito antes de comprar
alguma coisa eu avalio muito se eu
realmente preciso aquela roupa daquele
cosmético naquela comida daquele item
porque eu quero usar até o fim é usado
até o fim mesmo o que eu tenho em casa
eu também gosto menos dinheiro porque eu
faço os próprios médicos e os
ingredientes são mais baratos e os
produtos são multifuncionais como
hidratante que serve para todas as
partes do corpo não só para a mão nem só
por pé
além disso é eu uso - cosméticos porque
os cosméticos convencionais eles irritam
rezek e aí você precisa usar um pratão e
outro é porque o outro resseca então
hoje em dia eu antes usava quatro
produtos para cabelo hoje em uso só um
xampu em barra e que dura quatro meses
eu também gaúcho menos dinheiro porque
eu compro coisas de segunda mão
eu não tenho problema nenhum e nem
ninguém deveria ter encontrar coisas
usadas
então eu compro roupas e eletrônicos
usados sempre que eu posso
mas a principal mudança é saber que eu
faço tudo que eu posso para reduzir o
impacto no planeta brasileiro produz em
média cerca de um quilo de lixo por dia
e dormir sabendo que eu não contribuo
para essa estatística é muito bom
eu estou feliz porque os meus valores
são alinhados com o que eu pratico e
isso pra mim é o principal
tá mas por que eu deveria fazer uma
coisas estão pensando que eu tenho a ver
com isso
bom eu deixei mostramos exemplos para
vocês essa tartaruga foi achada por pior
biólogos na costa rica é eles viram que
ela tinha uma coisa na es e resolveram
ajudar a tirar é eu não vou mostrar o
vídeo para vocês porque ele é muito
triste mas sabe que é isso
era um canudinho inteiro imagina a dor
que essa tartaruga não sentiu
sabe-se lá por quanto tempo
nove em cada dez pássaros como em
plástico
isso significa que 90% dos pássaros
hoje em dia como plástico
vocês devem imaginar não é nada saudável
comer tampinha de garrafa isqueiro
canudinho pedacinho de plástico
muitos animais morrem por causa disso e
muitos animais podem ea instituição por
causa disso
assim a gente precisa fazer alguma coisa
estima se que em 2050 vai ter mais
plástico do que peixes nos oceanos
sim o problema é urgente a gente precisa
começar a fazer algo agora cerca de um
terço de toda a comida produzida no
mundo é desperdiçado seja no transporte
na distribuição na nossa casa
imaginar quanta energia não é usada para
produzir um vegetal um pedaço de carne
um sanduíche desde a água do plantio até
as pessoas todas que trabalharam o
transporte todo as cotas de gás
carbônico que se não são usadas para
produzir o alimento e aí que a gente faz
a gente compra um monte de coisa e tudo
bem estragou vai fora um pouquinho
passado hoje a gente cozinha hoje amanhã
já está mesmo muito bom a gente joga
fora
bom mas a gente pode fazer então para
começar a melhorar esse problema é a
primeira coisa é bem óbvio é como eu
falei a gente precisa aprender a
identificar que tipo de lixo que a gente
produz o que a gente faz que produz
resíduos que não é legal
e aí combater esses problemas
a segunda coisa que a gente precisa
fazer é separar o lixo
eu espero do fundo do meu coração que
todo mundo aqui separar seu lixo já sim
porque se não faz isso se não tem o lixo
reciclável em casa
assim demorou 2016 não dá mais tá
precisa separar o lixo é mas o problema
de a gente achar que a gente tá fazendo
100% da nossa parte e 100% do que a
gente pode fazer só separando o lixo é
esse em 2014 na última pesquisa do ciclo
o soft só 17% das cidades brasileiras
tinham coleta seletiva dessa são paulo
que têm coleta seletiva só atendeu 42%
da população
isso quer dizer que lá em são paulo
capital
7 milhões de pessoas não tiveram coleta
seletiva o caminhão não passou para 7
milhões de pessoas só lá são paulo
capital
o problema é urgente agora é por isso
que a gente não pode mais achar que
separar é suficiente a gente precisa
começar a aprender a não é não produzir
lixo e aí eu vou dar três ações simples
e que já vão começar a ser f k vejo
nisso pra vocês
o primeiro substitui descartáveis por
reutilizáveis ou seja guardanapo de pano
ao invés de papel caneca de café no
trabalho ao invés do copinho descartável
ecobag no lugar dessa campanha plástica
tá é coletor menstrual no lugar de
absorvente descartável fralda de pano no
lugar da fralda descartável
a segunda coisa é comprar a granel é
comprar a granel gente evita muito
embalagem ea gente compra a comida que a
gente vai querer na quantidade que a
gente precisa então se você não precisa
de um quilo de arroz se compra meio
quilo de arroz e você não desperdice
esta comida também terceiro tem uma
composteira doméstica em casa é metade
do lixo a gente produz é considerado
lixo orgânico ou seja a gente consegue
reduzir metade do nosso lixo e não
enviar a ele pra ter centário tendo uma
composteira em casa
se nós todos aqui se todo mundo tivesse
uma composteira em casa a gente evitar
por ano de enviar para os ateus
dário cerca de duas toneladas de lixo
lixo esse que vira adubo vira vida
cada pequeno passo é importante eu sei
essas são ações fáceis são mais
tranquilo de fazer e tem coisas que são
mais problemáticas né
eu mesmo demorei um ano para entender
todo o processo de como mudar minha
rotina o que assim a deco melhor a minha
vida daquelas cinco sacolas de lixo que
eu falei no começo que eu produzir toda
semana
hoje em dia eu só produzo uma sacola de
papel higiênico porque eu ainda não
parei de usar ele e uma sacola de
reciclável a cada duas três semanas
depende um pouco porque eu ainda preciso
comprar coisas que vêm embaladas
mas a gente não pode mais achar que
separar o lixo fazer nossa parte de
preciso ir além
a gente precisa deixar de produzir lixo
a gente só vai ter um mundo melhor
se a gente pensar em ter menos essa é
uma ideia que vale a pena espalhar por
aí seja mudança que você quer ver no
mundo
obrigada